sound wait did speaking scared you and
Tom oh my god that was the highlight for
me what in [ __ ] Winnipeg during the
soundcheck oh my god okay yeah I know
this is another [ __ ] I know this is
another sorry but I got to tell this one
too we got to tell us one too well so
this is this so this is right after the
[ __ ] gorilla okay
this is right after this happens we're
weirded the [ __ ] out there was a little
bit traumatized I'm a little bit
traumatized and we start testing we
start testing the mics okay all of a
sudden we're done testing everything we
put the mics down and this [ __ ] sound
this sound it was the loudest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life boomed out
of every single speaker in that place
yeah the [ __ ] don't even describe
that it sounded like Satan screaming so
this [ __ ] this like like vocal effect
plug-in like bugged out on the front of
house guys like monitor so it just came
through the entire building like it came
out of the monitors on stage that we use
to like hear ourselves it was just like
through everything it was just like
right there but so [ __ ] loud it was a
lot of thing I've ever heard in my
entire life I thought I thought the
world was ending I really did I thought
that something like a giant nuclear bomb
went off and that was it
I really truly thought in my heart of
hearts that I was dead so this sound
starts playing I was like I was too
hysterical to really articulate is after
I said it a little bit but this is how I
know I had I'm dead inside
I literally didn't feel fear I just like
I like close my eyes and like just held
my left hand up to my ear literally the
only thought that passed in my head was
turn that off
that's it like that's loud I open my
eyes I'm like aliens it's got to be
aliens or something I'm we're getting
abducted for sure my giant comet baby
big-ass asteroid big asteroid probably
who knows
Cody and Tom there I like your eyelids
are stapled back like you do look like
Jesus I can't describe it's gonna do the
thx commercial or whatever our hairs
flying back tom is just like at the
bottom of the stage she got the worst of
it cuz he was in front of all the
speakers in front of the speakers he's
just like what the [ __ ] just happened
I'm just standing on stage like this
[Laughter]
looking around like something like
welcome for shrapnel out of did I die
is this heaven Oh Winnipeg it's all like
what the [ __ ] was that
it's cured [ __ ] out of me and Cody
you're like oh my god me too
you're like I'm [ __ ] shaking and you
held out your hand and you're just like
jittering just started dying laughing at
how so differently we reacted to that
[ __ ] you two had the appropriate
response which is like fight or flight
like you guys were in flight mode and I
just went to sleep on my god I'm gonna
die like if the Armageddon happens I'm
just gonna look at it like damn I guess
it's like that huh mm-hmm
all right then I told the [ __ ] sound
dude I was like thanks man you I think
you cured my depression I they I could
feel good feel something now - man you
just hit that noise when you hit a low
you're like [ __ ] ah you know what I'm
gonna walk my dog [ __ ] so bad right
now
[Laughter]
this is literally how it sounded and
went for like 30 seconds
it was [ __ ] it so it was so scary it
was so scary I can't remember the last
time I've been that scared it was
scarring I felt really weird for the
next like three hours after that
happened like really on edge every
little noise I don't know why when
people get scared it's the funniest
[ __ ] [ __ ] to me I should not enjoy it
as much as I do I remember I scared the
[ __ ] out of my friend like fourth grade
I think I've said this before but like
he the way like his house was setup was
like he had this staircase and then like
it's like it's like lead like the
staircase came down and you made a left
and kept going straight you could see
into his room right so he ran up the
stairs to his parents for him to grab
like some video game and he comes
running down I'm standing basically like
in a hallway next to the stairs so he's
like running down the stairs straight
into his room and as he's going into his
room I just up time this shit's so
perfect I can hear him running down the
stairs he's like alright dude I'm gonna
[ __ ] like I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
like in like you know the game like he's
talking about the game and as he is like
maybe his face is like parallel with
mine
he [ __ ] jumps and screams like a
little girl and grabs his ankles in the
air he goes and he lands like on his
knees like sitting like a little baby
and then he just gets really mad at me
he said why would you do that he was so
sad why would you do that
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
then the new sound plugin just be
hitting different different [ __ ] weed
and alcohol we just need to do that [ __ ]
yeah that's like that's like the [ __ ]
that's like the hearing version of
smelling salts oh yeah yeah yeah as the
audio does I an ammonia with ammonia
that's high orals mouth oculars eyes or
Elizabeth what's ears um
audio auditory auditory yeah yeah okay
yeah it's the auditor right
no where's this coming from cuz I was
just thinking like it's it's you know
it's never mind it's hearing salts
that's what it is your salt near salts
yeah y'all want to talk about an alarm
clock [ __ ] up and sell it do you be
awake so fast there's no such thing as
sleeping in on that [ __ ] sound Jesus
Christ toast pop coffee's brewing just
one second sound asleep we got to turn
that into a sketch the Doomsday alarm
clock just makes you get ready so fast
just sounds like the end of the world is
a giant ass alien oh [ __ ] oh that's so
good the Armageddon clock man I'll write
that one down
wow that's really funny [ __ ] it a oh my
god I don't even think a gun could have
scared you guys that now No
Jesus Christ dude that was crazy how do
we even top that that was that was good
laughs
[Music]